the first epic trailer for the Captain
Underpants movie just dropped and as its
based on the best-selling book series
the movie looks like it will be packed
with Easter eggs and references to the
original novel Fridays cocaine
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'll be revealing some
cool Easter eggs and other interesting
details you might have missed in the
first full Captain Underpants movie
trailer so let's start with pranksters
George and Harold's we're creating
comics in a treehouse where you'll see
that in the middle of the floor is the
brand name they used for their comics
treehouse comics ink
there's also a robo burgers Easter egg
on one of the comic book covers we see
in the treehouse the Robo burgers are
monsters which appear in the Bionic brew
the boy books are the Captain Underpants
series and that you might expect from
their name there are technological
creations based on snot and there's
another hint to the Robo bruisers later
in the trailer visor stop co-sign on the
building that Captain Underpants runs
along okay let's get to Captain
Underpants himself as a trainer reveals
how George and Harold transformed their
mean principal Krupp George uses a hypno
reins hypnotize crust and make him think
he's the captain underpants character
from their comic books this
transformation is similar to the first
Captain Underpants book where George and
Harold use a hypno ring to hypnotize
corrupt when they want to recover a
videotape the principal's using to
blackmail them into performing chores
for him in the movie though it looks
like George and Harold use it to stop
corrupt putting them into separate
classes after crops been hypnotized
George snapped his fingers presumably
because he thinks it'll snap crap out of
his state however the snap kicks off
corrupts transformation in the books
whenever someone snaps their fingers
crisp automatically turns into Captain
Underpants and in the trailer after his
transformation he delivers his classic
catchphrase treadmill ah mr. Krupp aka
Captain Underpants is voiced by actor Ed
Helms he was one of the stars of The
Hangover movies so I wonder if George in
Harold's prank with the tiger could be a
hint to the first hangover movie where
Ed Helms sings a song about a tiger that
appears as part of a prank in his hotel
room in Las Vegas while Captain
Underpants is battling a giant
inflatable ape in the city skyline you
can see a billboard for John's House of
toilets a building which appears in part
2 of The Bionic brew the boy books in
that story Captain Underpants stand on
the top of John's house of toilets where
he performs the underpants dance to
annoy and bake the Robo burgers next up
in the trailer we get to meet professor
P
dresses rather amusingly that is not the
evil villain of the story
professor peas full name is professor
pipi pipi poopy pants and the character
was introduced in the fourth Captain
Underpants book and if you feel like you
recognize professor tees voice from
another recent animation that's because
it's Nick crawls the voice of the
all-singing all-dancing Pig Gunther and
the animated movie Singh and professor P
is clearly controlling this giant toilet
character who is likely turbo toilet mm
the leader of the talking toilets from
the second Captain Underpants book
attack of the talking toilets talking of
toilets it looks like George and Harold
played a prank on classmate Melvin while
he's demonstrating some kind of toilet
invention
Melvin's toilet invention is clearly
going haywire and this might be the
prank which got George and Harold into
so much trouble with principal Krupp
Melvin is the nemesis of George and
Harold in the attack of the talking
toilets books where he invents the patsy
mm a photocopier that can convert any 2d
image into a real object and in this
other shot it looks like Melvin is
teaming up with a nefarious professor P
interestingly an attack of the talking
toilets
it was Melvin's Patsy mm invention which
was responsible for the creation of the
talking toilets so I wonder if in this
movie Melvin and professor peen will be
the ones responsible for creating turbo
toilets when Captain Underpants takes
out two bank robbers at Frank's bank
it's a nod to the very first crime he
stopped in the first novel although in
that book it's because the robbers
couldn't stop laughing after he told
them to surrender or he'd use wedgie
power on them and finally did you spot
the amusing store called everything
except fabric softener the store for all
your non fabric softening needs well
it's a location that appears in a number
of the novels and as a name suggests it
sells almost everything but definitely
not fabric softener so what did you
think of the first Captain Underpants
trailer and were there any other Easter
eggs or interesting references you
spotted let me know in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this I really
appreciate you hitting that like button
and why not subscribe for more Easter
egg and animation videos and you can
also check out some more videos you
might like right here thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers